carlos es un artista afrodescendiente
sus trabajos son en esencia espejos en
los que vas descubriendo su identidad
qué es darle un rostro a esa identidad
negada por muchos años por muchas
décadas
a pesar de su cabello inconfundiblemente
afro durante mucho tiempo no fue
consciente de sus raíces en el último
censo poblacional del 2007 siete mil 441
personas se identificaron como afro
salvadoreñas
por los años que ha existido de negación
de la población afrodescendiente muy
difícilmente ahora las personas se auto
reconocen y además tratan de ocultar sus
rasgos que son mayormente visibles
la población africana llegó a el
salvador en el siglo 16 y fue sometida a
labores en hileras y mineras la
esclavitud se abolió en 1824 tres años
después de la independencia en honor a
ese hecho es que se erigió un monumento
el único en el país que dignifica a la
población negra hoy que se cumplen 200
años de esa liberación
de esa independencia los
afrodescendientes
los herederos de la huella de la
herencia africana en el salvador y en
muchas partes de centroamérica
seguimos desamparados seguimos olvidados
otra impulsora del movimiento afro
salvadoreño es quien si el día del
bicentenario salió a las calles para
reivindicar su orgullo afro no hemos
tenido políticas a favor que nosotros
los afro salvadoreños no merezcamos y
que nosotros nos sentamos podías hacer
nuestras raíces el salvador aún no
reconoce la afrodescendencia en su
constitución
el paso que podría terminar con la
invisibilización y la negación de la
negritud falta fuerza y lucha para
romper esa cadena